[Music]
HBO presents as if it wasn't bad enough
to try to figure out the difference
between HBO on your cable HBO Go HBO
Maxx and HBO now now we have HBO
presents HBO platforms can go themselves
to the max right now corduroy boners
boundaries coroner's seriously though
what's going on and what i mean by that
is how did it show with sloppy handheld
video poor sound and obviously
improvised scenes somehow become one of
the most prestige shows on cable there
are third graders on YouTube putting out
more polished content than this now like
a five-inch bunch up I got here
according to the real life documentary
bloodshot six inches is not even
impressive so I'm not sure what Larry is
so excited about here setting aside the
deep moral quandary about displaying a
clothed erection in public pants usually
only 10 like this while sitting so not
sure you need to worry about people
thinking you're out for a job walk at
this point I don't have anybody to go
with go by yourself Richard Lewis
calling Richard Lewis also are we really
having storylines about not wanting to
go to the movies by yourself in the year
2000 I'm pretty sure at this point going
to the movies by yourself is what heaven
is made of landlines also making your
wife answer the phone I thought managers
and agents we're always dodging their
clients phone calls like jumping into
bushes and when they walked by what kind
of a bizarro world is this
I hate shows that aren't realistic like
all the screwball comedies from the 30s
and 40s were playing off your
inappropriate use of the Hitler card
with I didn't know anyone else was
listening this show was made so long ago
that theaters hadn't figured out that
you could advertise upcoming films or
brand the theater on the cups and
buckets thankfully theaters would
eventually use that untapped income to
make sure they never had financial
issues again they're building for you
excuse me yeah exactly right can this
will end up being Richard Lewis's date
because the subtitle for Curb Your
Enthusiasm is actually the man of
never-ending convenient
misunderstandings wear that dress cuz to
want people to look at your shoes right
or possibly because she likes the way
she looks in it or she likes the color
or it was the only thing clean clothes
are not invitations they're decorations
grow up
[Music]
these evening on the aisle she's sitting
on the aisle she doesn't expect somebody
to come in I understand that Larry David
created Seinfeld and some characters
were based on people he knew and blah
blah blah but early Curb just feels like
Larry said you know what would have made
Seinfeld better me being in it and also
more mistake in erections also
considering his friend is sitting on the
complete opposite aisle maybe Larry
should have gone around I'll be up to
five o'clock in the morning if I have a
cup of coffee
I feel like I'll be up too late if I
drink coffee now has become the get off
my lawn of beverage conversations trill
Hines inner thoughts about the subject
matter of this episode somehow makes its
way into the script
sure would be enthusiastic at TV since I
mean I'm not gonna say that I called our
Hitler and you're your parents heard it
in the car
right why would you be honest with your
partner what a silly concept perhaps if
she wouldn't understand a joke maybe you
don't make the joke or perhaps don't
make a Hitler joke at all Bob called
episode will never resolve the case of
Bob Shaw and his need to say hi your
tips
okay yeah I'm ready too I'll color up is
that tin foil or plastic is that saran
wrap this goes on for some time though
come to think of it that's going on for
any time at all was pretty much ascend
or just big balls okay I mean
technically they're still brass they've
just had chemical balls inserted into
them but semantics let it call me later
on
bye-bye sundown by sundown Gary Cooper
if he was Gary Cooper he'd be asking you
to call him by High Noon Larry maybe you
need to be reading Emily Post or maybe
if you were actually mad instead of just
play-acting this poorly constructed
scenario you wouldn't even have to try
swear the show is Larry David basically
jerking around with his friends and then
tricky someone else to pay for it they
just say he and him for Sammy because
based on literally the least possible
amount of research I could do isn't
Sammy their daughter I'm honestly not
sure which is more unbelievable that a
grown human would assume an erection
based on bunched up pants that someone
would think this was important enough to
call the face-to-face meeting or that
once told about what really happened the
person would still find it so hard to
believe
Sophie
Ren was once a source I know my sources
Sophie Lauren was once a source so Larry
David plays Larry David
Cheryl play Cheryl Jeff plays Jeff and
Susie plays Susie this show is so lazy
they should have just called it curb
your effort and find a place for a table
of two and I just don't have one what's
happening is the same thing that happens
in every scene of the show someone
states the plot point in hand and then
the characters take turn reciting that
plot point in different ways like we
can't two people how about we can't sit
at a four and a four
anyhow they do this for a minute or so
until they get bored and start the next
plot point acting fish frenzy probably
nowhere because there is zero chance a
restaurant this nice has something
called a fish frenzy Denny's wouldn't
have something called that and they have
a dish called moons over my hammy how is
this crowding you can fit an entire
chair between Jeff and Susie they're
practically social distancing at the
table that's right she was mentioned
earlier so of course she's here we will
add check-offs Kathy Griffin to check
offs Richard Lewis's girlfriend
check-offs Hitler reference and
check-offs direction to the list of
things that have come back to haunt
Larry in this episode alone but I guess
that's the thing about check-offs
direction it's sure to pop up again
eventually this credit is now playing
music in your head and will for the next
three days
it's actually an optical illusion it's
the pattern on the pants that it's not
flawed flattering in the crotchal region
for some reason you all want to wear the
cinemasins pitchfork and on your body so
we slap that car on some new merchants
threw it in the store posters hoodies
tanks socks below the YouTube player
click the store link get cinemasins calm
Jerome come here for a second how you
doing
no is this Trevor do I sound like a
Trevor to you Eddie it's your dad is
your mother there uh no she's not back
to the shop yet and she's getting that
German there that you like for the match
are you looking at my breasts
I was not my intention I didn't stare
directly at them
you're like everything right now now I
did don't worry that's over now but I
try to be a nice human being
forget about